who do you think really runs the world
think about what things people are most
addicted to video games steroids
partying all of that stuff but what's
one of the most addicting things that
many of those guys can't get power the
of having a lot of power people that
look at you that are afraid of you some
people love that you know the quote like
if you really want to test someone's
character give him power I mean some
people really love having power take a
company and see some of the guys that
they hired they hired a wrong person at
the top the guy was all driven by power
what happens take a president that
becomes a president and he real he can
use the justice system against his
opponent those people I believe are out
there some of them are 100% money people
because money talks but there's also the
other Power Players behind closed doors
John Maxwell wrote about this in a book
saying the law of EF Hutton EF Hutton
was in the room that every time the guy
was making a decision he would have make
a decision until he asked about there's
a lot of those guys that are the brains
behind the faces that we see and most of
the times the best EF Hutton no one ever
finds out who those guys are